ich habe den neuesten und modernsten
Nachtzug der aktuell durch Deutschland
fährt getestet und bin damit in den
Skiurlaub Gefahren ob sich das preislich
lohnt verrate ich euch natürlich auch
erst seit wenigen Wochen fahren die
neuen ÖBB nightjets durch Europa neben
jeder Menge moderner Ausstattung gibt es
hier auch die neuen Mini cabins wie z.B
in japanischen Hotels die Reise startete
für uns in Hannover und innerhalb von 12
Stunden ist man dann irgendwann in
innsbrurg in Österreich leider hatten
wir direkt 90 Minuten Verspätung und
mussten am Bahnsteig warten na ja
irgendwann ist der Zug aber eingefahren
und sobald man für zwei Personen diese
Mini cabins bucht kann man die direkt
nebeneinander schlafen es gibt so eine
kleine Luke die kann man öffnen und das
ist echt cool zum Positiven der Zug ist
wirklich top modern und mega gut gedämmt
ich konnte echt gut schlafen die
Kabinenbeleuchtung kann man per Touch
steuern und in verschiedene Farben
einstellen und die Lüftung ist ungefähr
so wie im Flugzeug leider ist unser Zug
dann in Augsburg kaputt gegangen
aufgrund deer technischen Störung wir
mussten also raus und sind 3 Stunden zu
spät im Skigebiet angekommen ich habe
auf jeden Fall 320 € bezahlt also 160
pro Person wären wir pünktlich
angekommen preislich finde ich okay ein
eigenes Schlafabteil hätte aber sogar
580 €